obrigado
bom pessoal vamos lá eu começo
dividindo uma música com vocês essa
música me transporta até o momento
a música não foi essa música me leva até
eu tinha sete anos de idade eu lembro
que era um sábado de sol
eu estava no ombro do namorado da minha
prima chamado el món a prima se chama
solange eu nem sei se é uma ainda vivo
assim como várias outras crianças que
estavam no ombro ali dos adultos e alma
e perguntava você está vendo se estou
vendo que você vê uma loira de repente
aparece uma loira no meio do nada o que
ela está fazendo ela está dançando mas o
que mais você ver como ela estava
vestida está pelada e agora o que você
vê
eu vejo uma grátis mas o que está
acontecendo está ficando escuro e de
repente essa loira começa a virar um
macaco era monga a mulher macaco quem
aqui lembra da monga por favor levante a
mão
essa é uma memória emocional que eu
tenho do playcenter
desde os sete anos de idade foi assim
que essa marca se conectou comigo e eu
sempre tive curiosidade depois na vida
acadêmica de tentar entender como as
empresas vendem de forma diferente como
diferentes mercados atuam e essa minha
busca essa crise da dimmy levou a vários
questionamentos como por exemplo como a
gente faz para vender a jóia de um
milhão de dólares ou como a gente pode
fazer para vender se pegar um super
negócio ip
eu tive o prazer de conhecer o dono de
uma empresa de parafusos ué um mega
negócio
pergunto pra vocês quando os parafusos
existem aqui nessa sala hoje quando os
parafusos existe na sua sala no seu
quarto no seu carro até a cabeça da
gente às vezes precisa de parafuso e
essa busca ainda me buscar e me levou a
tentar entender eu tive o privilégio de
conhecer o seu domingos lá em manaus
o dono da funerária cada ano morre hoje
em é amanhã
e lá fui visitá lo dentro do seu
showroom e ele falou que não tinha
marketing que ele entendia de nada
desfila fui visitá lo ao chegar haviam
duas placas
a primeira era ano empresarial 3 reais
por vida mínimo ter mil funcionários um
plano familiar r$12 família toda 15
inclui a sogra megera por marketing
depois da assistência mortuária eu fui
entender eu quis entender como se vende
vestido de noiva e essa busca me levou
allen foi uma loucura eu tive a
oportunidade de ir passar um dia num
lugar em são paulo e cônico chamado rua
são caetano
o belo sábado de janeiro são mais de dez
anos lá fui eu
uma amiga minha percorrer esta rua não
sei se alguém aqui conhece
ao chegar na rua sábado 8 da manhã de
janeiro estava super brasil por conta
das férias
nós chegamos a gente viu uma loja a loja
não tinha aberto o placar loja abril
começamos a observar os detidos
a vendedora nos abordou olha que nós
temos os dez vestidos mais vendidos e os
lançamentos mas temos mais nós temos
mais de 80 modelos
aproveitando o dia do seu casamento
noiva e amiga da noiva coisa nenhuma nem
olhou me diz confiável é outubro a
vender outubro amigo em outubro elton
começou uma discussão
chegamos à conclusão é outubro a
vendedora disse então temos tempo para
fazer o casamento dos seus sonhos
vocês querem dar uma olhada nos vestidos
minha amiga não não eu viro não a gente
quer ver
nós subimos haviam duas salas no andar
de cima nós somos
pressionados por uma sala que compunham
uma mesa cinco cadeiras um espelho na
parede 10 interruptores de uma caixa no
chão aqui a mesma coisa mesa cadeira
espelho interruptor e caixa no chão e
ele também
nós sentamos a vendedora trouxe um
catálogo amiga começou a folhear o
catálogo simplesmente comentou olha esse
que lindo ea vendedora 03 gente oito e
meia da manhã mais um pouquinho olha
esse lindo 0 15 passaram 30 segundos de
uma senhora com um mancebo de rodinha e
ali estavam 03 e 10 15
a vendedora virou e falou experimenta de
ensino obtido dos seus sonhos e amiga
não experimenta pelo amor de deus eu não
posso experimentar o vestido é minha
amiga foi experimentou o vestido a
vendedora em cheio de alfinetes nas
costas o vestido ficou justo e gritou
júnior
quanto às mitologias aparece um menino
do nada e pergunta pra minha amiga como
você imagina a sua maquiagem para o
casamento
nessa mesma hora ele começou a puxar
pincéis ali entre os bolsos e maquiar a
minha amiga
ao finalizar a maquiagem ele virou véu
curto médio ou cumprido foi desculpa
cumprido é o comprido ver um véu
comprido
a vendedora simplesmente virou pra mim e
disse 'por favor suba no queijinho que
era aquela caixinha na frente do espelho
ali minha amiga subiu a vendedora
apertou todos os interruptores
simultaneamente à luz daquela sala toda
pagou só ficou uma crônica assim como
estou aqui em cima da minha amiga que
ainda girava o vestido inteiro brilho
ela virou você está linda palmas para a
noiva começou a bater palma todas as
outras vendedoras começaram a bater
palmas clientes começaram a bater palma
eu falei fui eu vou ter que comprar um
vestido e eu não estava preparado pra
isso
nessa mesma hora ou se uma marcha
nupcial na sala do lado e eu vi ele fala
que tá rolando ali era uma fuga do meu
cérebro
você pode simular a sua entrada no altar
com vestido quer fazer minha amiga não
foi sequer fazer agora vamos lá fazer
esse negócio
é minha amiga fomos lá para outra sala o
júnior era otimização de recursos e de
maquiavel e também era o noivo
chegamos lá a noiva estava terminando o
desfile dela avó chorando a mãe chorando
as vizinhas chorando todo mundo chorando
a noiva aos prantos
a vendedora me chega nessa menina e
coloca a mão nela com firmeza olha para
os olhos dela diz regina diz que quando
a gente chora é porque esse é o vestido
das duas uma ou é verdade é macumba
eu só virei pra minha amiga foi você não
chora pelo amor de jesus
saímos dali entramos na loja do lado
havia um bife à outra loja tinha um
desfile da minha imagem ea outra loja
tinha uma orquestra com caixas de som
para o lado de fora que tocavam músicas
que recuavam pela são caetano
todos vêm de uma mesma coisa mas o
contexto ea forma como ele se conectavam
com os consumidores eram totalmente era
totalmente distinta e diferente e essa
busca essas minhas curiosidades me
buscaram entender porque como as
memórias são criadas
eu dividi aqui uma memória que eu tenho
que mora emocional as memórias são
criadas de duas maneiras emoção ou
repetição dividir com vocês aqui um
emocional cada um de vocês
possui uma e vamos lembrar aqui que
algumas memórias repetitivas da nossa
cultura que fazem parte do nosso dia a
dia
não sei quem lembra mas não é por acaso
que até hoje nós dizemos não é uma
brastemp
eu me chamo fernando eu sofri nos anos
80 porque as pessoas falavam bonita
camisa fernandinho e assim para as
marcas se criaram como taí um corneto
conectomia equipe e mostrou é da gelato
porque outro lembrando disso ou uma
econômica mapa e venha correndo map
chegou a hora mapping é a liquidação e
essa é mais próxima
vamos lá saiu aqui temos lá corneto
mapim
a procurar para curar tomou doril a dor
mais barato mais barato piracanjuba
eymael um democrata cristão
ok e assim as marcas se construíram as
nossas cabeças de forma simples
ok então vou convidar vocês a cantar
comigo vocês me ajuda em nome de jesus
vamos cantar um ícone que está em nossas
cabeças de quase toda uma geração desde
os anos 80 e até hoje me ajuda para não
pagar mico sozinho aqui com a monga
eu vou contar até três ea gente vai com
cantar todos os ingredientes que
complementam um big mac
então vou contar eu posso correr vocês
me ajudam vamos lá 1 232 hambúrgueres
alface queijo molho especial cebola e
picles não pão com gergelim é o pink mec
big mac gente não faz o menor sentido eu
tive em ouro preto e fiz essa música e
todo mundo sabia cantar
não tenho é que dona de ouro preto fiz
essa mesma brincadeira no acre não tem
máquinas no acre
vejam como a marca tem um poder
econômico transcendente isso é incrível
como as coisas conseguem se conectar com
as nossas cabeças
nós precisamos ter um olhar mitológico
para as coisas eu sou um profissional de
marketing
adoro comunicação só que eu vejo que
hoje o marketing não que não deva mas só
discutir sobre a internet das coisas crm
bi a&e data coisas blá blá blá que não
tem o menor sentido sendo que a target
que é um grande mercado americano já
usava de estatística nos anos 70 para
entender o comportamento de compra das
pessoas a gente virou por a tecnologia
não que isso não seja importante no
marketing
nós entendemos tudo sobre tecnologia
ultimamente só que nós não entendemos
nada de mitologia do consumo e quando
pergunto cordas ou topológica biológica
filosófico ou psicológico de alguém
comprar um produto muitas vezes as áreas
de marketing não conseguem responder
porque nós não temos tempo para fazer um
tipo de análise porque a gente só tem
que gerar roy
tem que gerar lide nisso a gente
constrói marcas que não se conectam com
as pessoas entendendo disse querendo
seguir adiante
existe nós é uma máxima da shell a
patente chan
quando você tenta fatia de divisão de
atenção das pessoas
toda marca numa quantia divisão do seu
dia na sua missão
só tem saúde está no facebook os planos
que a gente tem que estar no trânsito da
economia nem de coisa está na sala
ultimados prazo nós temos eu acredito
que um grande aliado de roubar
talvez o senhor a tendência das pessoas
é o comportamento de consumo previsível
não tenho nada contra quem usa essas
marcas eu não tenho nada contra essas
marcas
mas hoje os rapazes do brasil são uma
camiseta de uma marca chamada rota uma
calça djalma chamado diesel o anterior
marca chamada após 51 iphone e um i30
que as pessoas comam o adesivo do iphone
dos seus 30 anos e as mulheres a nação
mais que elas têm mais com cortes de
marketing ipam se as pessoas são control
c control v
mas ela se achou únicas e exclusivas os
mesmos gestos que se compraram em
outlets em miami
isso é triste eu costumo dizer que na
nossa sociedade as pessoas com as minhas
roupas pela semestre e não os livros
pelas médias e quando leio um livro mas
nem 50 tons de cinza ou a culpa das
técnicas assim fica muito difícil a
gente dar um passo à frente e eu não sei
se vocês já viram isso pra mim isso a
conversa de elevador de shopping
elevador no mundo corporativo onde eu
tive até o ano passado eu vejo aqui
grandes executivos que já seguiram outro
caminho e o meu caminho se encurtou anos
aos 37 anos eu entendo a busca que ele
faz e o que ele fez na carreira
não sei se você já viu isso no dia a dia
de vocês
ai meu casamento meu casamento é top meu
marido é top mexido foi top a noite não
foi top minha filha a princesa
adversário vai ser do frozen da minha
filha e descoordenada fronza né
na voz carreira fato a guerreira se a
fifa guerreira e avós é fugir da guerra
com a atividade é uma guerreira rádio
ativa não faz o menor sentido
a gente vive no país das maravilhas ou
no mundo da lua essa é a minha pergunta
somos todos famílias goianas no final
das contas nós vamos pro baile de iná
palavra mas nós mexemos pessoas da
família da pobreza não conhece o levante
a mão ou perguntando se chama um
pensador contemporâneo
não vou trazer algum tempo quando o
placar era uma cantora muito falsa canô
é esse outro é uma personalidade
incrível porque ele é 99% ante perfeito
mas aquele gol por cento é vagabundo
esse próximo adoro porque sonhar nunca
desisto itv mc de aniversário de imagem
3 milhões de reais
andré e depois nós temos uma lendária
o'connell joelma
biggs o que dá pouco amigos e eu convido
vocês a seguir todos eles no instagram a
vida dos ricos e famosos como civil
celebridades já a partida sem clichês é
muito fácil se não eles
a gente não pára observar que no meio
dessa crise que existe para uns e não
para outros que se dizem de mim essas
personalidades fator mais que se aí os
essa é a grande pergunta e ao final de
tudo eles são consumidores
só que o nosso preconceito como
marketing enxergar nos enxergar nos nós
vivemos uma crise sem talvez este seja o
momento onde o público alvo não está
consumindo um produto analisar aquele um
dos 101 público que não desenvolvia e
desenvolver e dar uma atenção distinta
pele é isso que as áreas de marketing e
às vezes o nosso próprio preconceito não
nos permite fazer seu ninho é todos nós
somos seres simbólicos as marcas possuem
o poder de criar simbologia para falar
de produtos marcas e pessoas é preciso
entender simbologia eu fui fazer um
símbolo que vale muito hoje que foi
construído um pouco tenha nele ele é
isso quem sabe
a pergunta está favorável a essa grande
com a construção simbólica essa mesma
coisa sozinho
vamos ver esta simbologia
estamos falando da mesma tecnologia da
sua marca nas mesas a sua condicional
as pessoas deveriam se no único a
diferença entre itaú ano em construiu
isso uma comunicação inventado quanto mz
bin laden conseguiu esconder no qual
dilma não importa a forma que nos podem
levar como as pessoas fazem é isso que
as grandes empresas não consegue
entender
[Música]
é isso que nós todos lhe ia conseguir
chegar a uma nova narrativa para chegar
e conseguir falar do fla é a simbologia
da criare é construída em diversos
aspectos do nosso dia a dia somos os
anos ser simbólico cinema e as 10
tecnologias todos os sons conseguido
terminar aqui em encerrar dentro do
tempo é um desafio pra mim muito grande
nós vivemos um momento das conexões
emocionais
o crm quero castro e shanxi planejamento
agora é cliente relationship management
onde as marcas vão ter que ter cada vez
mais idéias para fazer com que as
pessoas cada vez mais amigos seus
produtos
quando nós amamos produtos e marcas ou
temos relações emocionais seja de
respeito pela marca seja por perceber
que ela é transparente
os valores são verdadeiros uma colecção
foi estabelecida e assim de fato as
marcas podem fazer mais sentido para o
próximo
eu agradeço e espero que eu tenha
contribuído hoje aqui pra vocês e pra
mim as empresas do futuro o marketing do
futuro
as empresas vão precisar de alguma
maneira girar dos consumidores
diferentes emoções sensações e
sentimentos
assim elas fazem sentido e não somente
ser um produto por um produto muito
obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]